hey everybody and welcome to a smashing
wild ride with steo we've got Michael
Chandler arguably the most exciting
fighter in the UFC I mean this guy just
stands and bangs I mean come on he says
he's not here for a long time he's here
for a good time and he fights that way
man we had a good time talking to him as
well he's a classy guy and we talked
about a lot lot of unclassy stuff so
without further Ado let's get into
it ladies and
gentlemen Michael Chandler what's up
we're here yeah dude we were supposed to
do this in Nashville yep on the card
that s Corey sandhagen and Rob font
fought but my lady and I were looking at
properties and we had like uh scheduled
like visits to properties and and so I
had to cancel on you that's more
important well dud we got the property
saying so now now you live closer or you
have a property closer to closer to me
so I'll take it so we both live in
Tennessee yeah exactly soep how long ago
did you moved to Tennessee man I was
here it's been seven years now so I
actually was just talking I just got
bodyw work this morning and I was
talking I was kind of doing the math cuz
I grew up in Missouri so outside of
Missouri I lived in San Diego for 5
years or so and then now it's been
Nashville has been the longest I've
lived anywhere else besides Missouri
where I grew up so seven years help me
out what's Bodywork body just massage
yeah basically massage but like massage
sounds like you know little tranquil
music and like Kumbaya like rest mine's
like he's digging into all these big you
know big knots and stuff I just flew
back from Vegas yesterday so like hips
are a little tight from sitting on a
plane yeah how about Vegas dud Vegas was
good UFC 296 it was a a good good car
was how close were you to the uh the
fight between oh my gosh actually so I'm
in every almost every single one of the
videos popping around cuz I was I
actually missed the jump I just heard a
bunch of commotion and my manager like
looked over my side of my shoulder and I
looked over and they and I saw I saw
Strickland had already thrown the
punches and now he was going elbows um
so I'm in 126 completely illegal UniFi
unified rules of mix martial arts but in
the crowd you can pretty much do
whatever you want it's a street fight
just get the kids out of the way they
did though did you hear about that
because it was it was Gilbert burns his
wife Bruna and their two boys were just
sweetest people in the world but they
were literally on the underneath the
freaking trajectory so they told him to
move and then they probably didn't think
nobody thought he was going to actually
jump over now that I watched the videos
but he did he's Sean Strickland so dude
the Dana's response to uh just the
question or whatever about about Sean
Strickland politely asking the kids to
get out of way it was so funny man yeah
I mean it is actually hilarious because
you know he it actually kind of it's
really kind of cool cuz it shows a
little bit of self-awareness where he's
like hey I can't be trusted I know I
know what I'm about to do but let me at
least uh just tell you Qui you know and
anybody else who was like Hey move move
move nothing will actually happen but
it's Sean Strickland and that's why
that's why we freaking love him man like
he's he's just a freaking fun dude to
watch he's uh he's he's a wild card man
um dude so uh D so tweet um about Colby
oh yeah uh you said for aot who talked
what did you well for a guy who talks
about everyone being triggered he sure
was afraid to pull the trigger and then
I also said if his if his offense
tonight was an accurate depiction of us
strength we would have never got gained
our independence Lost World War I and
got demoralized in World War II now I
only say that because I don't like to
talk a lot of trash and never do I ever
want to step on a guy when he's down
after he loses right because I hate when
people do that to me we all hate it but
whenever you've created such a fake
character like you've become the
character it's like well I'm not
actually hating on Co Covington the
heartbeat the guy outside of just the
fighting you're hating on the character
just like it's WWE and funny thing is I
just I think he crossed the line I think
he's a sure I just he's I don't know
he's not my style I think he and I might
actually agree on a decent amount of
things but I think his delivery is just
asinine so the line is dead people well
yeah I mean murdered father and like
yeah I mean what he said about Leon what
I mean and even I mean I mean family in
general oh for sure but that yeah that
was just one example and he's just I
mean I don't know it's but I also I
think it's uh for me a guy who I just am
who I am I don't really try to play a
character I mean yeah of course every
now and then you get pumped up when
you're on the microphone and maybe
you're a little bit more aggressive or a
little bit more whatever but actually
playing a a character and you know it
just it just doesn't sit well with me
and I just think he the wrong I I don't
buy it anyway because uh yeah oh that
you know he's actually a sweet guy but
like he does this
character if you're a sweet guy then
you're not like you know degrading
people you know yeah I mean there's
there's a line you won't cross you
there's a line you won't let your your
character cross you know just like just
like there could be like actual actors
who are like hey I'm an actor and I'll
do anything in this fantasy world that
we call you know film but I have a
certain things that I I don't want to do
on camera or whatever like it's I don't
know it's uh yeah he and I are not I've
actually never spoken a word to the guy
but I do have mutual friends who are
like oh I swear he's a nice guy I'm like
maybe yeah CH really backs him yeah CH
and C Cameron Haynes you know Cameron
Haynes uh I don't think I do great
friends with Joe Rogan he's on Joan all
the time he's bow hunter uh marathon
runner guy um just a stud but they're
both from Oregon right um so uh
you were entertaining the idea of going
to
welterweight for for Connor yeah and
then didn't Connor say some stupid thing
like we're gonna fight it middleweight
yeah yeah I mean you know Connor's uh I
guess the way I saw it was so after the
the headkick of Tony Ferguson and the
crazy the crazy postf fight speech that
people love it kind of worked out really
well I think that's what really parlayed
the whole Connor thing I said I wanted
to fight him at 170 because he was so
big you know he was you know he was
doing the Roadhouse movie which is
finally going to come out here soon um
and he was big he was beefy and acting
like he was really really big so I was
like okay there's no way he's going to
fight 155 I don't want to fight 155 I
weigh like 190 I would love to fight 170
so I figured I'd do the call out at 170
and then yeah Connor Connor likes to uh
act like he's in control so he like he
could have said 205 and and I would been
like okay I'll fight you wherever dude
like right cuz I truly I I'm bigger than
Connor I'm not he's not that big at all
he looks big he's got really great
angles and really great camera uh camera
photography work and Lighting in all of
his photos and stuff I mean I don't know
dude hisence changed in a mighty way and
uh I mean him not being in the usada
pool and and uh it being generally
accepted to heal like broken bones with
all kinds of uh you know
steroids um I mean he just got a pass
for uh you know taking steroids because
he broke his leg is my take on it and he
kind of took that pass and just went way
overboard to where his entire appearance
just went bananas he got big yeah and
just his face like uh I mean what the
hell mean isn't that like a Telltale
sign when like your jaw and your
forehead get big yeah I mean and part of
that too you know part of that too cuz
I've I've gained weight and ballooned up
after fights I mean after the gatei
fight I was I was nursing all the leg
kicks that he that I took to my lower
body and then I was also the leg kicks
that I threw on him my lower body was
kind of trash for the better part of six
weeks so when you can't do much with
your lower body you know you're going to
naturally your cardio your ability to do
cardio goes down so obviously when
Connor was limping around for what the
better part of a year after two snapped
bones he was naturally going to gain
weight but yeah his the how big his face
got yeah but you're not getting like
Bond CH I mean like the dude some of
those photos you know you can't help but
to think man are they photoshopped
because it's that drastic or know jacked
he jacked big he's a big boy but then
when I saw him CU you got to remember
too he's a natural 145 pounder I still
think he's a natural 145 pounder I
actually made fun of him saying he has
the bone density of an of an albatross
he's got bird bones like he's he's like
he's a thinner lighter guy right you
know um lot of power he's very good
athlete
but lot of power on the left or at least
he used to he used to and that's what
everybody says oh you're you're just a a
stocky wrestler with an overhand right
Conor's going to snipe you with that
left hand it's like yeah maybe the Conor
from 2018 would you know when he was
when he had his timing on he he was more
consistent he was actually fighting
trying to fight for and get to the
titles so now he's just fighting to get
back at all so yeah are you guys going
to fight is that the
question that is a good question but let
me ask you this question what do you
think is the most well-reviewed product
we've ever promoted on the Wild Ride
podcast I dare say that it is Aeropress
because they've got
55,000 five star reviews this is for
someone who takes their coffee seriously
and if you know anything about me you
know I am that person so what do we do
with this thing we don't French Press we
don't drip we Arrow Press over here and
now that I'm in Tennessee I'm full-blown
country
and I am literally pulling a cast iron
skillet out of the
fireplace and dumping it in my arrow
press like a true badass oh my God how's
this going to
work get the out of
here now I have pulled it out of the
fireplace and I've got my plunger in
there and I'm doing the thing man Arrow
Press so satisfying dude and man is this
Epic Coffee they actually have
competitions for Aero press like there's
world champion
Baristas and you got to try it plus
they've got a huge offer for you if you
go to aerop
press.com
sto Aero press.com that's a r o p r
ss.com
steo you can get up to 20% off this
extreme ex affordable AO press coffee
maker I mean dude less than 50 bucks
it's epic and it's the perfect Christmas
gift so go to Aero
press.com steo for up to 20% off your
order and start drinking coffee like a
real badass and there you have it ladies
and gentlemen the perfect Christmas gift
for the last minute white elephant
Shopper at Aero press.com
/o up to 20% off now let's get back to
it we are going to fight and I I think
right now he's trying to wait me out I
mean because if you were him would you
want would you want to wait as long as
possible for the guy like me who's a
real fighter who wants to be in there
who wants to compete so so that I say
screw it I'm going to go fight someone
else and then he can go fight an easier
fight Nate Diaz he can go fight an
easier fight Tony Ferguson he can go
find a much easier fight than fighting
me so I think ton fuson is now off the
the table Yeah I think that's off the
table and that was that was tough to
watch man cuz Tony's a legend Tony's you
know but I mean the photo of your foot
to his face is probably the gnarliest
photo in all of UFC yeah I mean the
Frankie Edgar with Cheeto and you and
Tony those ones where you're like is
that photoshopped you're like no for
that Split Second in time that slice of
time they actually looked like like that
man it's it's uh it's pretty like even
even even the skin on the cheeks went
straight South you know somehow do you
have that photo hanging up anywhere in
your gym I don't I don't can't dude I
don't you know I definitely thought
about making some t-shirts or something
like that you tattoed we'll see yeah no
I mean I mean it's one of those things
too I mean even I even did just actually
posted reposted the video of but I
really only did it because Joe Rogan was
talking about the freaking look at
Chandler's body he's like a ball of
muscle exploding on your face and Shane
Gillis was on there they started
laughing it was more about how funny
that clip was than me actually punching
ing Tony or kicking Tony in the head but
yeah do you think Tony looked better in
your fight or his fight uh two days ago
I think he looked better in my fight I
think he he was slower you know it's
tough I mean the fights in fights in re
in re in person look a lot slower than
when you watch on TV in general so maybe
it's a little bit biased and of course I
have you know I have reasons to say he
was better a year or two ago when I
fought him than than now but he really
did he really did look a a lot lower and
absolutely you know but he had moments
in every one of those was it six or
seven fights that he lost before Patty
he he had moments where yeah and it's
and it's tough too because MMA math and
you look at the guys he fought I mean
what what was the first loss it was I
think it was Justin gatei you was it
olera maybe I think I think it was gate
oh no it was Olivera or wait it was one
of the two back toback it was either
aliver then G here gatei and Olivera so
two top guys in the world then me you
know so like half half of those losses
were to like the world class top five
guys so but then after he's lost the
last couple well he lost to benil daru
so that's another top five guy so that's
strength of schedule is a real thing
when it comes to you know fighting it's
it's not it's not just like you lost six
fights you lost like even me people can
talk about my record all they want
that's fine yeah I'm two and three in
the UFC but I fought everybody inside
the top three or top five right and
whatever you know here's an interesting
one I was sitting next to Cory sandhagen
and Madison Square Gardens
uh two fights ago two pay-per-views and
uh I told him how I came to Nashville
and I was in the arena when he fought
Rob font and he said oh dude I'm sorry
about that it was such a boring fight
and I
said I said imagine think of it this way
Corey
like there's no other sport in the world
where you're going to get a hard time
and people be like oh dude he was just
trying to win yeah yeah no well they
just had to do what they had to win but
in fighting we're like you suck get up
blood you know right he had a torn he
literally tore his tricep in the first
round so I mean I don't know how I would
respond in that scenario I've had
injuries here and there but nothing like
a torn tricep you know I would have
definitely held on for dear life but
it's just an interesting thing that like
you know it's like if you like you owe
entertainment to the fans and it's a
sport where you just want to win so like
it's not okay to just want to win and by
that same logic
you have recognized the the importance
of entertainment and fighting and you've
just gone in there and like dude you're
like this alltime wrestler and like
we've not seen any wrestling out of you
in the UF yeah yeah I mean I think I
fight within my specific skill set I
mean it really does feel natural to me
to go make it chaotic and go make it a
dog fight and make it be dangerous I
mean and that's that's part of where the
criticism comes comes with like this
last one with Colby it's like yeah I
mean you can talk about my record I
haven't won every fight I get it but you
have never ever once said damn Chandler
was in a boring fight you know right we
don't because he you know and part of it
you know part of it maybe people say
well if he would just use his wrestling
maybe he would have won this fight or
would have won that fight but we will
never know that and I also think just
like there's punches kicks knees and
elbows and there's these techniques of
the sport techniques of the game plan
being in somebody's face keeping your
foot on the gas trying to trying to
break a man is a technique maybe it's no
doesn't always translate into a win but
it's it's definitely part of it and uh
it's a lot more fun that way I mean that
that gaii fight was absolutely fight of
the year yeah yeah that was 2021 fight
of the year um could be one of those
ones that go down in history as a you
know they do the Hall of Fame fights
which is you know that'll be cool
whether you win or lose I mean that's
that's part of it too and that's and
that's a metaphor for life as well you
know it's not all about the wins and the
losses you know and that's what I say
too and of course I can say it cuz I
haven't won every fight it's an easy cop
out for me to say hey I might not have
won but I did make you feel something
right dear I made you feel something I
made you want to go do something more
than what you're doing right now because
you saw me go out there with my heart on
my sleeve go out on my shield maybe it
works out maybe it doesn't but it's even
if you lose you win whenever you're when
you're truly operating within your
passion for sure and and dude I I fell
in love with Cory sanen so I'm not going
to I'm not going to bash the guy but the
reality is even though he got the W
against Rob font his profile took a hit
yeah and you took the L with with G
gatei porier Ola uh but every one of
those fights improved your profile yeah
I mean if you if you can if you can lose
and still win you're you keep on winning
you know that's the way and I and that's
honestly how every single one of my
fights or losses wins or losses have
been every single time I've stepped
Inside the Cage my profile has increased
whe whether it's whether with a win or
whether it's with a loss you know a
devastating knockout sometimes doesn't
even get you as much jump in profile as
a crazy fight of the Year where you take
a loss against Justin gate you m Square
Garden you know so it's that's why we
love fighting though that's why people
aren't just fans of it they they they
attach themselves to it and they live it
because it's such a fun fun Sport and
the UFC is does it better than anybody
as you know you've probably been to all
the promotions you know I love it man
I'm a psycho I'm a psycho for it um so
this Conor fight I mean like uh it
seems like you're kind of getting jerked
around a little bit like now like I mean
has there ever even been a season of The
Ultimate Fighter where the two coaches
didn't fight there's been one season and
it was the last time Connor was on it
but that being said he it was yah Faber
who was a 135 so they were two weight
glasses apart essentially they were
different weight classes and I think it
just made sense kah was a star Conor was
a rising star star at that point um but
this time I mean that's and that's the
thing I've you know it looks really bad
on everybody's part if Connor comes back
and doesn't fight me after The Ultimate
Fighter right so Conor can try to come
back and act like he runs the show and
say I want to fight this guy I want to
fight that guy which I if I was in his
position if I was his manager I would be
trying to do the same thing because
fighting me is not the smartest fight
you know it's a great way to come back
in if you beat me you're in the top five
in lightweight division you know but
also there's a lot of easier fights and
and and there could even be some bigger
fights but not really people people are
chopping at the bit to see me come back
because I because of the entertainment
value that I bring I've had a full year
to train and think about this guy at
this point if it's you know at this
point hopefully it could be UFC 300
that's the next one that they're yeah
announcing maybe they announce us on
there that'd be great if they did I have
not been told that we have but it would
be great at what point do you like say
okay it like I won't fight like is
there things in the contract where it
says you can't wait so long for an
opponent to fight once you guys sign the
dotted line it's a good question no
there's not anything contractually um so
really it's just personal preference I
mean yeah I mean I could have jumped off
this this wagon you know six months ago
but um I've enjoyed this time off you
know I really have I mean I've been
signed with the UFC for three years and
I've had six training camps fought for a
world title fight of the year I've had
four four performance of the night night
bonuses out of five fights so every
single time it's either some kind of czy
spectacle or it's a or it's a fight of
the night or it's a knockout of the
night performance of the night so it's
been it's been a whirlwind I've spent
more time away from my family over the
last three years than I have with my
family so being having a full year here
you know we're celebrating Christmas
here in a couple days like this is the
first time I'm going to get to enjoy a
Christmas and a Thanksgiving and all
this stuff doing a lot of stuff outside
of the Octagon business-wise um that's
going to carry me on past fighting so
it's been a it's been a really good year
so I've enjoyed it and uh sometimes
patience is a the coiling him a spring
for something even better so that's why
I'm looking at it um to Scott's question
you don't have to accept any fights in
your contract but the UFC does have to
offer you fights yeah but didn't you
already sign a fight with Connor saying
you guys will fight yeah I mean our
ultimate fighter contract says that yeah
so we we're pretty much under that you
know and like I said if I was Conor I'd
just keep waiting waiting as long as
possible and then it's and it's such a
nobody's better at the pr game and the
manipulation of the headlines and
getting in the headlines than Connor and
his team right they're that's why you
still see them aiar just a couple days
ago his manager was you know talking
yeah Chandler is probably the most
likely opponent but there's still other
options out there it's like no there's
not any other options out there Audie
but it's smart for you to say that yeah
um it's smart for you to try to get
inside my head that this fight might not
actually happen little do you know I'm
bulletproof and I'm fine I'm do to be
just fine um and I can wait this out as
long as you want you want to try to
retire me I'll retire you right back
that's what cha said it was like it was
funny CH did he's like okay Chandler's
playing the long game here you want to
try to retire me you want to try to wait
me out okay wait me out I'm going to
wait you out just as long because I I
will stand firm in this conviction that
this fight is happening and there's only
one way to get back to the UFC and the
road goes through Nashville
Tennessee let me tell you something
about coming through Nashville Tennessee
it's epic I absolutely love it here and
since I came here I became obsessed with
chopping firewood and I'll tell you I'm
just getting off by the day burning
calories working out just with firewood
and you know how I know that because I
wear a whoop band and let me tell you it
is so satisfying to go to bed knowing
that you really put in the work that you
really
really had your darn calories burned man
it's a good good feeling and then it's
also a really good feeling to know that
you got great sleep and that you spent a
bunch of it in in that R stage and man I
love my whoop app it tells me about how
I sleep how I burn calories what
activities I'm into what's my heart rate
variability I mean this is the most
sophisticated Fitness tracking device on
Earth and they're giving the listeners
of the Wild Ride podcast 10% off
membership and you can't beat that so I
suggest that you get on the whoop train
and start going to bed knowing that you
kicked butt during that day and like
you're going to love it so go to
whoop.com that's wh
o.com and use the promo code steo for
10% off your membership again you're
going to feel real good about yourself
if you do this so whoop.com promo code
steo and let's get back to
it so all right I mean Colby didn't
fight for a full two years and I just
assumed that that was uh because he's
suing mzd doll yeah I thought right like
I just assumed that like if if he was uh
like cleared by a commission to fight
then that would like you know undermine
his uh you know claims in in the court
of law oh yeah because there was some
kind of injury or something you know
yeah he's trying to say he has brain
damage but if he if he gets if he gets
in the Octagon then his whole argument
is kind of out the window yeah but it
sounds a lot more like what they're
saying is that he was just literally
holding out for a title shot yeah I mean
and that's and that's where you know you
you have the luxury of of you know being
friends with the guys and knowing what's
going on behind the scenes and the brass
and the UFC like people have no idea
what goes on behind the scenes on a
daytoday basis with these guys putting
on the biggest sporting events in the
entire world filling Arenas all around
the entire world all of these different
matchups dealing with a bunch of
freaking lunatics you know these guys
got all their own ulterior motives they
got their preferences the UFC has their
power like they got it's a big Power
struggle Non-Stop and as the UFC keeps
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
like you said more guys want to hold out
or more guys want to more guys want to
insert their opinion which is great I
mean I you want us individual fighters
to have our own opinion have our stand
on our own two feet and say no this is
what I want to do I'm not going to be
strong armed or whatever it may be but
it's uh what these guys have to deal
with UFC like Dana Hunter Campbell Sean
Shelby Mick Mater these guys on a
day-to-day basis week toe basis card by
card basis is nuts you know right so and
and the whole like fighter pay
thing um if you look at the UFC as a
business like it it the way they do it
makes perfect sense it does I mean yeah
in any business you know any business
you got to start in the mail room and
then work your way up right right or you
started in the mail room somewhere else
and then you end up working your way up
like it's life is a meritocracy you get
what you you get what you put in
whatever your Merit is you will then get
compensated more and more and more and
it's tough because it's not if you look
at fighter pay compared to other
organizations the fighter pay isn't off
as a matter of fact there's only one way
to get truly truly rich and financially
wealthy in the sport and that's through
the UFC however all you know a lot of
the other guys who are working their way
up you know they start out off at a low
salary just like everybody starts off at
a low salary in a certain business in a
certain sector and then as meritocracies
would have it the more you bring to the
table the more you get paid right but it
the argument is tough because all people
say is well the UFC is making this much
so therefore they should be sharing that
with the fighters the employees the
independent contractors whatever but if
you look at other organizations that's
just because they're not as profitable
it's just because they're not as good of
a product they don't they don't reinvest
into the sport it'll reinvest into
building the entire sport so you're
saying like Bellator might pay a larger
percentage of their revenue to the
fighters but there's just less Revenue
tons of less Revenue there's almost no
there's almost no revenue and there's no
almost no reinvestment so I was the
biggest name in Bellator for the last
five years I was there my last five
fights I had a camera on me one time I
came to the UFC in the first 6 months at
they were flying out to my house to do
this little this little piece and follow
me in the the UFC countdown and then
getting ready for this and get I me they
are they reinvest hundreds of millions
of dollars back into the UFC every year
which is really into the sport of mixed
martial arts because they have
quarterbacked and championed the entire
sport to raise the elevation and that
Rising tide has raised All Ships pfl
Bellator one Championship everyone else
yeah they they on on the Patrick Bet
David podcast they pulled up the p&l
statement for UFC and they ran if you
look at the p&l statement payroll
for the UFC accounted for like 44% of
the expenses the rest of it with
marketing and all the reinvestment they
do to grow the business you know so what
you're saying is like on Bellator the
payroll might be 70% of the revenue that
they you know the expenses that they
bring in but zero marketing zero I mean
not zero I'm not going to say zero but
and that's what I would say too because
people are talking about pfl and
Bellator the the now the new
conglomerate and I'm say well there's
only one thing that they need to do in
order to continue to gain this profile
and that's spend more money on marketing
and they're doing a good job they got
Francis enanu they got Jake Paul and
there's these other guys who can be a a
mouthpiece and be a be a a big platform
type of person to be able to help grow
the entire the entire brand but I uh hit
up I hit up Ariel helwani after the
enanu fight because he um I saw a tweet
that he put out and it was uh you know
he was defending the pay-per-view
numbers that that inano Fury fight did
like everyone said it was only this many
you know like and and he says yeah well
that you're not counting uh you know
International pay-per-views and and you
know and and everywhere and and I just
hit up arel I said why are you even
defending the uh the pay-per-views on
that like they're besides the point
because you know even if we assume that
it was a catastrophic failure and no
body saw
it doesn't change the fact that
everybody heard about the fact that
enanu shocked the world and now
everybody is ready to mark their
calendars to hand over their money to
watching ganu box again yeah like so
doesn't even matter like that his dues
are paid and it doesn't matter what that
fight did business-wise because his next
fight is the whole bag true yeah so so
the so what you're saying say is the the
general storyline was hey look look at
how big this fight was supposed to be
and it didn't do as as good of numbers
as we thought and there is some truth to
that too I mean everybody you know pfl
has tried to do it Bellator they did it
you know and they sold like 100,000
pay-per-views or less you know it's like
the UFC they just put on this show and
they sell pay-per-view and they do it
because they because everyone knows
about it man it was it was the most
frustrating thing for me to to know
training alongside all these UFC guys
and I put more work lived a better
Championship lifestyle than they did
beating them in the in the practice room
I was the guy I was living that that
champion lifestyle yet my fight would be
happening and there would be a UFC Fight
Night that same weekend and they would
send all the first string reporters to
there we'd get the second string
reporters if we got any it just seemed
like such a smaller deal than even a
mediocre UFC card and that's the brand
that they have built so maybe I'm a
brown noser and a boot licker and all
that stuff that everyone you know calls
me but it's like I just understand the
business and I've been around the
business and I have the luxury of
knowing what it's like to be outside of
the UFC right and then coming into the
UFC and then watching it just go you
know so why doesn't everybody why do
they go to the Bellator is it because
it's harder to get into the UFC it's not
hard to get in the UFC and that's and
that's not a knock on the UFC I I sit
here now today it's like the UFC will
give you a shot you get a shot why would
you choose any under of these
organizations um the I mean I could tell
you years ago the reason I took to I had
a a Strike Force contract and a Bellator
contract on on the table at the exact
same time I took the Bellator contract
cuz that was back when they started that
was back when they used to do these
tournaments fight three fights in three
months and then you get a shot at the
world title from me that was Eddie
Alvarez a top five guy so I saw that
clear path for me to be able to hit that
rocket ship and I did all of that won
the world title became top five guy now
these days obviously you would go to pfl
because there's a chance you can make
that million dollar that million dollar
tournament makes sense but it also is
five fights in order to get that million
dollars so they can always say look they
made a million dollars but you got to
fight a lot of times for it um it just
depend I mean I if if I was if I was a
young guy right now I would look at it
and say because it's not about getting
to the UFC it's about getting in the UFC
and then staying in the UFC and building
it building there that's why I like a
guy like sha Ali I like a guy like Patty
pinet these guys who they said publicly
after they would beat somebody and say
okayy what's next you going to fight a
top five guy next fight a top 10 guy
next and their answer was simple no not
until I make more money am I going to
jump up into that that that rank to be
able to fight these guys be be look at
it like it's a slow burn look at it's
like look at it like it's a career not
just a not just a catapult because it's
not about getting to the UFC it's about
staying there and then being 37 years
old after 15 years of fighting and
looking back and saying man I made a lot
of good decisions to be able to get put
in a good position instead of coming to
the UFC becoming a flash in the pan go
back to the bars of my hometown and say
guys I'm in the UFC I'm a cool guy and
then two fights later you're out and
then you got to fight your way back in
So guys look at the outside of the UFC
in order to build the platform build
their notoriety their social media
platforms their merch sales their
whatever to then be a more highly
valuable product whenever they come over
to the UFC like I did as a kind of a
bigname guy coming to the UFC yeah yeah
you and Ben asran had to have been the
biggest Acquisitions from other
organizations yeah I mean and then now
looking at my you know my career so far
in the UFC It's been a it's been a
mutually beneficial uh you know career
move for me and the UFC you know and I
always knew that I wanted to be in the
UFC I just didn't know if the
opportunity was going to arise if that
door was going to be wide open for me to
go and it just made too much sense
whenever the time arose and here we are
uh who's this MVP Guy where did he come
from he's in Bellator uh or sorry was in
Bellator now he's in the UFC and I
thought it looked like he signed with
the pfl a couple weeks ago is that the
guy who's like 68 um no no that's
another taekwon doe guy um I don't know
who that is but Michael Venom pagee um I
got Michael Venom page yeah I got mixed
feelings about him I don't like his
style I think it's annoying um he just
kind of like moves around and moves like
a what's that drunken you know like
drunken karate warrior style where they
like kind of move around he
does yeah yeah like stuff like that but
you know but he's got some when I say
ridiculous like Knockouts the dude's got
some ridiculous walk-off spinning
kicks and back elbows and broken
people's faces and all kinds of really
he's a highlight reel kind of guy but
does it translate well I think Kevin
Holland's a horrible matchup for him I
think Kevin Holland probably beats him
um but I like MVP I as a person I think
he's pretty cool dude but um yeah that
was a tough photo he got knocked out in
that one but we all get knocked out it's
all right how about uh Patty pimble man
he looked really good indeed Patty's
performance at UFC 296 was a good look
but you know what is not a good look
getting caught with a filthy
embarrassing bad habit I mean there's
just too many people out there slipping
like that and today's sponsor is the
solution it's called fume it's a
diffusive device which helps you drop a
bad habit by replacing it with a good
habit and I love my fume so much that I
always have it in my pocket and I have a
standing bet slofer to all of you people
out there if you see me in person ask me
do you have your fume in your pocket and
if for any reason I don't I will
absolutely shoot a shout out video on
the spot for your buddies and candidly
uh I've done it anyway for everybody who
asked me that question and I did have it
in my pocket I just love this I love
this product I love this brand it helps
people live happier healthier lives
lives and you can get 10% off your
journey pack if you go to
tri.com that's TR r y
fm.com and use the promo code steo it's
10% off your journey pack and why is it
called Journey pack because your journey
to a better happier healthy you starts
atrium.com with the promo code steo 10%
off the journey
pack Tri fume
and use the promo carde steo now let's
get back to
it pat he looked good yeah I mean uh he
looked huge yeah didn't he look big he
he looked big he's he's definitely
growing into that 155 he didn't look
that big the last couple years you know
I think he he came back from that injury
and he's looking looking good uh
probably has a lot to do with not
ballooning in between camps that's tough
man it's really really tough because
your your body can only handle so much
of that that yo-yo I mean it's it's
natural we all I mean I weigh 155 and
then all of a sudden I get up to 185 190
healthy right so that's a big weight
discrepancy but whenever you look at a
guy yeah when you look at a guy and
you're visibly like holy cow you got a
five gallon head and you you don't want
to take your shirt off if you do get
caught with your shirt off and you're
like holy cow you don't look like a
professional athlete cuz Patty looked I
was looking I was watching his postf
fight speech and there was a a camera
angle behind him you could see his his
his shoulder and back and neck and trap
muscles which is a a good indication of
of a lean body right so he it's it's
very very tough when you put your body
through these weight cuts and then
balloon back up get out of shape it's
just it's not good for the human body at
all let alone an athlete yeah and I mean
just from like not even a health
perspective but if it's all fat and
you're getting rid of the fat then like
you know what's going on with the muscle
you know exactly Scott says he he looked
huge because there wasn't all of this
distribution of fat going on it was just
like you know but his like shoulders and
arms were like double the size they
we had Patty on the podcast and and
before before we rolled the van over to
him we stopped and bought a scale oh God
oh God yeah what was he he got on the
scale I think he was like 205 dude was
so that was when he was born he was in
between camps it was the night we
because then after we went to dinner it
was the night that uh Leon head kicked
uh Kamar oh gosh yeah it was the same
day because we went to dinner and dude
Patty's great man like I you know like I
I really think he he looked great
against Tony Ferguson I think that that
whole debacle with Ariel helwani and and
the the way that the you know the
decision with Jared Gordon yeah um I I
think that that represented like growing
pains you know like you just can't
become like this big sensation this huge
star any kind of like like you know
public profile that you
get comes with growing paints you know
you can't just be bestowed Prestige and
power and influence and not like you
know kind of get it get out of control
with a little well and yeah I mean heavy
is the crown man the more platform you
get the more notoriety you get the more
the more that this this brand of each
person builds the even more diligent you
have to be with the basics and the
discipline because there now with that
great blessing comes even more and more
and more diligence that you have to have
because because then it's just it's
becomes easier and easier when you got
things being thrown at you and you have
options you have and then you have the
ego like it's human nature for everyone
to think man I got this ego man I'm that
guy and I've always tried to Tamper that
down so much because right you know
heavy is the crown but man high is the
fall whenever whenever those guys you
know similar to like this past weekend I
mean Colby deserves to have as much hate
as he has GI getting right now because
of what he built up and if you want to
say okay I'll do it did try to sell
pay-per-views cool dude well now you can
you know eat your shoe because you you
know embar ways to sell pay-per-views I
think Patty came out that whole debacle
you know like with visible humility you
know I really really think that he uh I
think that he's he's in between camps
taking him taking his career seriously I
think is he's improving as a fighter I
think he's got humility like just as a
person from the experience and and I'm
I'm rooting for him to to get knock G
with you yeah yeah me too he's he's I
mean he's good and and uh the BT Sports
he did a uh an interview with BT Sports
and they were talking about I went up
and I went and found him and
congratulated him or whatever and he was
said some really nice things about how
I'm a nice guy in the sport and you got
to root for me and so we have that
relationship and I have I have no ego
either I I come from the wrestling
background where it's like dude I could
be next to a guy that I'm going to fight
and we weighing at the same time like it
doesn't matter to me I don't need to
have this bravado and have to hate
everybody in my weight class because if
I fight you I'm going to try to rip your
head off and words were good but Patty's
whenever you start you know you kind of
come in you get that high and you get
that trajectory like Patty got then
comes okay now I really need to take a
step back and look at okay who who am I
how do I want to live how do I want to
be remembered how do I want each day
Brick by Boring Brick to be able to
build this thing so that I don't become
a flash in the pan because it could have
been very easily for him to if he lost
that fight to Jared Gordon now he gets
knocked down if he if he comes out now
he loses to Tony Ferguson before you
know it you're on the chopping block and
people were like well you were just a
flash in the pan with a interesting
haircut and a cool accent and there's a
million of you right so so it's cool to
see him visibly taking it more seriously
because i' yeah I'd love to share the
octagon with him sometime someday we'll
see yeah man they that that that would
be super cool man I'm I'm rooting for
him um tell us about the the stuff that
you're doing um
business-wise man so uh we just
announced my ownership in hius Tequila
so we didn't so we uh so I actually
about a year a little over a year ago um
I met the owners of Hiatus tequila the
founder of Hiatus tequila um but before
that I I thought about starting my own
tequila company and then when I found
Hiatus tried Hiatus realized okay this
is exactly what I would would have want
have created from a a visual standpoint
it's a beautiful bottle it's additive
free certified kosher the guy who
founded it Christopher doto just very
very passionate about uh Agave spirits
and doing it the right way so I was like
hey let me invest he said no said come
on let me invest he said no so I finally
wore him down and he was gracious enough
to let me come in invest and become an
equity partner um I'm an equity partner
in cram nutrition I got to send you some
of these I should have brought you some
they're uh it's it's a a better
healthier version of the uncrustable so
it's a on on the go PB&J sandwich oh wow
yeah speed Fitness um they we we have a
commercial and home piece of equipment
that Rivals the toonol toonol goes up to
200 lb our ours goes up to 2,000 lb
resistance and it's got a lot of really
awesome technology um we have I have my
own fitness app walk- on Fitness so we
got thousands of people in that
Community where we just create cool
programs for get people nutrition
mindset and uh workout stuff and uh just
a bunch of Investments man just trying
to build it your epic your degree was in
business finance personal finance
personal financial management services
with an emphasis in real estate yeah so
how how much has that com into play like
you're actually using your college
degree yeah in real life yeah outside of
the yeah I mean yeah I mean and really
the funny thing is just like anything
it's not it's not what you know it's who
you know i' I've been very blessed to
have some really very smart friends
around me my relationship Capital Bank
is very very very very deep um because
although I didn't have this huge
reputation or sorry I had a good
reputation but not a huge platform when
I was outside of the UFC so it just I
had to wait for that good reputation and
that big platform to meet to finally
start to capitalize on all the
opportunities that I have so um with
great platform comes you know great
opportunities and I get to vet through
and find out exactly what makes me tick
what do I believe in who do I believe in
and uh it's worked out pretty good so
far did that big man are you doing any
uh commentating I I saw that they like
uh you you were commentating with anic
and Cormier what was that for um the
anak and um and and maybe I've got well
no so so they do they do the cage side
stuff which is I forget what that's
called that's the commentary yeah I more
did the the the uh analyst stuff like on
ESPN cut to you know cut to the pre-show
the post yeah and I en I enjoyed that um
I definitely think it's something I
would like to do after my career you
know right now it's just I'm so busy
with other things that you know make me
you know
more make me tick more than that you
know I mean I I have uh I have a studio
in my backyard too where I can kind of
sit sit in my backyard and break down
fights and do it on my own and own it
myself rather than just going on ESPN
and doing it I did just uh get connected
with a I think it's Roger sportnet or
something like that with Canada so
there's a new Canadian thing coming in
so I'm going to connect with those guys
and kind of see what we can't think
about doing but I enjoy it I enjoy the
sport I'm not as passionate about the
actual sport X's and O's as people think
I would be I'm pretty darn good at
talking about it but I don't I don't
really study the sport as much as people
probably think I do you know mhm but
it's uh I'm I'm pretty decent at it so I
guess I'll keep dabbling here and there
that's crazy man um so
uh coming back to to Conor and I just
he's now back in the usada pool has like
changed back to the Connor of old to
look at him yeah he's looks like he
could he looks like he's training a lot
you know that's the thing whether he's
is training just for those 15 seconds
and puts out a clip or he's training for
hours and you know he looks like he's
training and he's getting in better
shape so I don't know what the holdup is
Connor yeah certainly looks like it's
trying like but that's got to affect you
like like what happened to TJ TJ
Dillashaw after he stopped doing the
like performance enhancing drugs and he
fought again against who he came back
that was cuz he went down to Flyway but
he slower was he like what happens after
you he lost way too much weight dude
like he had no Chin left at 125 yeah and
that's and that's a real thing too man
this this weight cutting thing is is no
joke man it's it's you're you're going
in there a shell of of the human being
that you're supposed to be right and and
to your point your previous Point too
about you know being on a certain
supplement regimen and then changing
your supplement regimen whatever that
may be I mean I've always I've always
right I've always just I've always just
looked at it like a crutch I really have
I always thought if
cuz if you if you get used to that you
get used to that feeling a certain way
and having that much power or having
that greater recovery and then all of a
sudden you know you can't stay on it all
of a sudden all I would be thinking
about is okay well I'm not as good as I
was six weeks ago so now I'm carrying
that lack of lack of confidence in and
you see it so I mean we'll see uh we'll
see how he comes back and performs I
feel like it's like a like a mark cerr
situation right like well Mark cerr was
more like like actual like opiates you
know it wasn't he wasn't doing roids
he's I mean sure he was but like
the the mark ker story was one of like
drug abuse not like perform per
performance enhancing drugs Yeah well
yeah I mean I mean we all we're all
human beings and we are prone to wander
and we we go through tough tough times
and there's there's so many you
especially when you talk about an
athlete or whether you know pro wrestler
Pro fighter these guys I mean they get
get stuck in things and stuck in ruts
and I mean even you look at Conor he's
been off for all these years and and you
know like we talking about go back to
his his training videos that he's
posting now it's much much nicer to be
seeing him getting caught training than
getting caught right wherever he was
with some cell phone somewhere on TMZ so
it's you know and it's I have never
lived the life of Connor like I haven't
I haven't lived the day in his shoes so
I'm not going to sit here and and judge
a man but the dude was you know he was
living life for sure you know I uh I
said what I said about growing pains in
uh the context of of Patty and I think
that that's like it's jarring to become
like a a you know very public
personality very quickly but o over the
course of like a longer period of time
something that khib said was pretty
incredible uh you
know an interviewer said to kib yeah
well Conor with all this money of course
he's going to get and kib said no money
doesn't change you money uh money um
enhan it reveals you yeah yeah it it it
uh it exag whatever whoever you are give
the give that person like hundred
million dollars they just are more of
who they are yeah no for sure I mean
yeah you see that like give a give a
person power and then watch watch how
they truly respond you mean and that's
what people have talked about whether it
be drug or alcohol or whatever people
like oh alcohol makes him this does it
really make him that or does it just get
really reveal does it really like pull
out who he has and and it's and that's
not to judge anybody who has probably
had those thoughts like man I probably
shouldn't drink or should do this or
shouldn't do that because it pulls this
out of me it's like we all have these
deep wounds that we're trying to heal
that we're trying to get through we're
human beings and we live on it we're on
this rock spinning it you know however
many miles an hour 8 billion people on
this Earth just trying to figure this
thing out called life and it's uh it's
hard and it's troubling and it's tough
and it's but it's also beautiful and
Blissful if we can find out how to
figure it out yeah remembering Daniel
TSH is like dude if I had a million
dollars I'd be rolling around jerking
off in people's faces all day like I
just you know that's what he would do
with that money I just it's funny I
don't know why I just thought about that
but well because Daniel Tosh is
hilarious so so now the the UFC
relationship with usada and and a couple
weeks January 1 they they turn over to
the new the new one yeah and what's the
new one so the new one um don't quote me
I think it's drug-free sport
International um I believe it's the one
that the uh NFL uses NHL NLB I could be
wrong I did just meet George Piro who's
the head of that um this past weekend
Jeff nitzki who was the who's kind of
the the UFC guy for that yeah the head
of kind of the UFC um sport performance
SL drug test testing whatever that may
be um that's one thing about the UFC
they have so many employees they have
such a ridiculously deep crew of high
functioning individuals um so yeah I
mean it'll be interesting I did how I
have the app on my or I don't know if I
have the app but I went to the website
on my phone doing the new whereabouts
thing so they're going to know where
we're at similar to usada there was a
lot of growing there was a lot of tough
things with usada people didn't like I
always enjoyed it cuz I I liked knowing
that everyone had to be a part of usada
and they knew where I was times but when
you're a sober member of Alcoholic
Anonymous you don't mind getting pulled
over by the cops yeah exactly right yeah
yeah exactly I was always like I you're
like hey does that suck and I'm like no
I actually always kind of like and I
always liked it whenever people were at
my house I always I always liked that it
was cool like duck duck duck knock on
the door and I got like a couple friends
over like sorry guys I got to go pee in
a cup real quick I thought it was it
it's another cool thing that I'll
someday Miss like it's it's another I
think it was a a cool thing um which
we'll still have that now under whatever
the new drug testing thing is called
we're still going to have that they're
still going to show up unannounced
they're still going to call us and say
hey you got two hours to show up or
whatever it may be um but I think it's
you know more than anything it is tough
because under usada it was so it was so
regimented and so so scary because you
weren't ever sure what was what was
legal what's not what's a supplement
what's natural what's not it's like at
some point yeah I want to be able to
fight and and perform but I also want to
be able to play baseball in the front
yard with my kids six years from now
when I'm retired I want to I want to be
able to be somewhat of a biohacker
somewhat of a live the life live the
life of a guy who's trying to heal his
brain heal his body be performing at a
high level just as a human being so it's
there's a lot of red tape and there's a
lot of almost I feel like you saw it
even like with the IV thing we couldn't
take IVs which I don't know if we're
going to be take be able to take IVs
with the new thing but it's you're just
like dude it's sailing solution in the
body I don't yeah like a Myers cocktail
you couldn't do that no we couldn't take
any over 100 MLS or 100 cc's or vitamin
C no yeah rehydrating with IV seems like
let's give give us a break over here
yeah well then some people would say
well they they wanted to Outlaw those
because people were going to use those
to mask other peeds or something right
it's like drinking a gallon of water so
you can pass a p test yeah exactly right
so it's okay I don't know I I get it and
you want to have a clean sport but you
also don't want it to be so over
overbear that all I'm all I am relegated
to is a protein shake and a multivitamin
it's like dude I fight in a cage for
living and I I live this crazy lifestyle
let me let me let me uh enhance my body
as much as I can legally right there's
of course things that we should never
ever ever be able to take that are 100%
performance-enhancing drugs 100% but let
me be healthy you know and we'll
hopefully during no in the
next the next uh rendition of the drug
testing thing that we can be like hey
there are these are these are things
that are 100% legal and 100% not
performance-enhancing I don't know we'll
see let me let me ask you this and I'm
surprised I haven't asked every single
person from the UFC this question um one
pint of blood a pint is 16 ounces so
presumably that's one pound
like have you ever heard of somebody
just donating a pint of blood to
make weight I have not no no I I have
not I mean I not a bad idea I mean I've
heard obviously all the all the ones
like freaking you know these guys you
know like taking an enema freaking try
to dump as much as you can shaving your
head like all these other things but no
no I haven't um it probably wouldn't be
good for like it wouldn't bode well for
your
performance it would deplete you you got
to get drug onto the scales you just
lost gives blood to make weight for
Battlegrounds MMA wow there you go that
was
2014 yeah almost a decade well I mean
that's almost a decade
ago wow that's uh so how I wonder how
that goes down is you know what like
what like to be I mean it sounds like
Lance Armstrong but if you took out
a pint and then made weight and then put
it back in that's illegal so that's
literally right any anytime you pull
blood out and then put it back in it's
it's the actual definition of blood
doping whether it was out for 5 minutes
or whether it was out for but but when
people do that is it their own blood or
yeah so I think what the cyclists were
doing was they would they would pull it
out and then train train train make
their body produce more of it and then
put it back in so then you have more
blood blood cells or blood or blood
oxygen blood oxygen something yeah I I
wonder what would trigger a because if
you're if it's just your own blood it's
not you're not going to like trigger any
drug test like what like how would they
how would they identify that yeah no I
mean I guess you technically would have
to get caught I think that's probably
how those cyclists got caught like
actual you know undercover people with
cameras and mhm you watch those
documentaries and Icarus and all those
other ones you know I mean dude like the
blood doping that's two birds with one
stone bro like you make weight like
that's an extra pound you don't have to
shed and you get the get get it back in
there I don't know what's something
definitely illegal what's something
that's illegal that like you wouldn't
think is illegal for like like that
would show up on a drug test you're like
I can't believe I can't even take this
like well like even even
creatine uh no creatine creatine's good
no I mean but but there's there's
certain things that are illegal in
competition and out of competition so
like if you get a sinus infection pseudo
pseudo fed pseudo fedrin or whatever you
can take that like I can take that right
now because I'm not in competition
within the first within 48 hours or 72
hours of a fight but I can't it can't be
in my system right before a fight now
one of those things once again it's not
performance- enhancing it's it's to get
over a sickness but it's still on the
band substance list um yeah but the
edin edrin I can well you can use you
can make meth right yeah well yeah all
the stimulants are are off like I mean
you gotta that's why the when the guy
did the inhaler that was a no no yeah
yeah Greg Hardy yeah Greg Hardy Greg
Hardy did the inhaler and then
in between rounds he's like ask for
forgiveness not permission he's like oh
I figured I could do it right yeah dude
that was hilarious I liked
watching Greg Hardy yeah he was he was a
wild card man yeah but it's even it's
even uh you know you've been to a bunch
of fights probably walked back and been
around kind of the locker room scenario
where we're all training and and getting
ready we always have a commissioner with
us one person like you would be with me
the entire time if I go to the bathroom
you got to go watch and see what I'm
doing cuz especially when you think
about where the sport started right you
know where where the sport started I
mean there was definitely dudes doing
drugs like right before they went out
there like kind of a little bit off The
Rocker like hey I need to do this to
then go fight right so it became this
regulated thing where this person my
commissioner will be with me at all
times and I can't bring I can't bring
anything with me they they give me water
they give me like coconut water they
give me a granola bar I can't bring my
own if I wanted to do a protein shake
can't do it if I wanted to BR starting
when like right when I get to the arena
I try to bring a cram nutrition peanut
butter and jelly with me and and like
they're like no you got to throw it out
so they because you could literally
get in trouble because it's not what
they gave you because they don't want
outside substances food drinks all that
stuff wow like what's an example of
something that you could take after
arriving at the arena immediately before
the fight that would benefit you during
the
fight um well you're not allowed to take
anything like they don't let youat
literally give um if they give it to you
like if I brought my own if I brought my
own Gatorade in with me they'd say no
throw it away let's say it could be
contaminated it could be I could have my
own supplements in there how would they
know like they drugged it do they test
you before you fight no but it's it's
more just it's more just hey you can't
have anything with you if you you need
something okay let me go get it for you
you know if you need you know in which
really they'd be like no sorry you get
water you want a Gatorade here here's a
Gatorade if you want you know you want
coffee let me bring it to you you can't
bring your own coffee did they weigh you
um right before you get in the Octagon
no not right before but there has been
there has been some some times where
they'll actually the UFC usually does
that they'll they'll weigh you and I
don't know if it's a commission thing or
if it's a you know cuz I mean they're
they're trying to regulate the whole
weight cutting thing you know they don't
I mean I'll weigh at 155 the next day
I'm easily 175 gain 20 lbs and I'll
really gain like 20 lbs that night I'll
go to bed at 175 and water mainly yeah
two gallons of water is 16 lbs so before
you know it now I'm at 171 eat a little
bit of food here 175 no problem
um crazy so like when like somebody gets
to weigh and say like when Izzy went up
to 205 to fight Yan bovic and and he was
like under the limit like anytime a
fighter like goes to the way we in and
weighs like less than the limit like
that then oo that that's a disadvantage
for that fighter yeah yeah I mean I mean
and yeah I mean you always try to
basically when you're cutting when
you're cutting it's usually for me I
would get down to 155 cuz I know I'm
going to float a little bit and I'm if
I'm 155 on my scale I would already
check it and know if my my scale is a a
pound heavy a pound light to the the
check scale because there was actually
one one fight I think it was MSG no it
was uh Arizona when I fought Ferguson
and Charles Olivera missed weight
because uh because the check scale was
was jacked up the check scale somehow
got jacked up that I remember one fight
when when you know when I think it was
at fight island or something I think it
was like they they were saying that that
uh how is that possible well the the
problem is with scales you know you I
could take a scale we could take a scale
right here and we can step on it we
could pick it up and then we could go
over to my house or whatever picking it
up moving around it can it can get kind
of jacked up and if you don't know that
it's jacked up or or you know with a
check scale it's sitting in a hotel room
nobody's watching it the entire time
they kind of loosely watch it but you
got to make sure no one Jacks it up or
steps on it falls on it drops something
on it picks it up and moves it and it
could change half pound pound easily
there was a championship fight where
somebody didn't make weight and they
were not eligible for I think that was
Aliva fight yeah it was ala right of
course it was I think it was Arizona and
that's where I fought and I can I can
attest that check scale got jacked up
cuz I that was it I checked myself on
the check scale and I thought it was x
amount of pounds ounces off of my scale
but it actually turned out to be light
or heavy tripped and it was a jacked
scale yeah it's and it's it's it's tough
and it's you know because it's such a
that's why the the weight cutting thing
is just tough man it'd be cool if there
was more of a a range I don't know then
again I've never missed weight I've
never pulled out a fight so I'm kind of
a hard ass about it I'm like hey
freaking show up and make weight but it
is tough like when that stuff I haven't
asked you about Ian
Gary I mean talk about a guy getting
on so he he's gone through a lot as
of late you know these last couple weeks
and then now he pulls out of the fight
due to sickness pneumonia you know and
then I thought it was interesting too
now he is scheduled to fight a different
guy Jeff Neil Jeff Neil which is great
because he made that T-shirt with Jeff
Neil's mug shot like but so why did that
fight not happen Jeff Neil pulled out of
the fight originally
uh why I don't they were supposed to
fight right you know I don't remember
yeah it's tough I mean once again I'm
I'm friends with Ian like you know we we
we've trained together I don't know if
we still trained together I don't know
if he's still trained youry I don't know
if he still training I I honestly don't
know for teammates you know at this
point um probably say B you're not yeah
I mean I think so and he was supposed to
fight vente who trains with us in
Florida um so my my opinion of of Ian I
like him he and I are very different and
it's not necessarily his fault like I I
don't I'm it's hard for me to be around
him because he's so like positive and L
fair and all this and like talkative and
all this stuff during training camp and
I'm like a psychopath don't talk to me
don't look at me type of guy so our
personalities during training camp are a
little bit different so it's it doesn't
doesn't mean he's you know not not a
cool dude but I saw I saw the way he's
been handling stuff lately is tough I I
yeah it's tough I saw a comment on uh
one of my like YouTube MMA do you watch
that like full Mount MMA like all these
MMA daily news channels not much I watch
all that sh I love it I I love it all
and uh a lot of these channels will have
um like the top three comments from the
previous video and the comments are
always pretty juicy it's worth worth
sticking around for especially on full
Mount MMA shout out to that channel okay
and uh there is this one comment said um
that Ian Gary is uh you know doing
exactly what Conor McGregor did except
he went straight to the part where
everybody doesn't like him he SK over he
skipped over the being being a uh being
a hero to his fellow his fellow
countrymen yeah so so funny I mean part
of that I mean it's definitely some
juicy headlines right now there's
definitely a lot of which that's what I
see now it's it's it's a little bit you
know interesting that he pulled out of
this fight because of pneumonia sickness
or whatever it was iudo was talking
about it yeah because I mean you skip
media day so everybody's like okay the
pressure's getting to him it's too much
he's not you know he skipped media day
then all of a sudden he goes from
skipping media day to pulling out of the
fight and you're like it's pretty easy
and very hard to it's hard to prove that
he has pneumonia are hard to prove
everybody everybody uh vouched for the
pneumonia being real but but what Henry
cejudo said is that when you're like
once you start doubting yourself when
you're in a bad mental place that's when
your immune system is is so it's just
like you know like he had gotten a me he
was mentally weak is the argument it was
a self-fulfilling Pro prophecy right you
know because you heo he plays a tough
guy on camera and he plays a tough guy
on the microphone yeah he's a good
fighter
but you we all we all succumb to those
those mental you know negative thoughts
negative feelings I mean there's a there
was a lot of stuff going on I mean
that's that's why I don't like the whole
animosity thing like I I don't it it
would not sit well with me and I I'm
self-aware enough to know like I don't
want this kind of crazy public on the
microphone on the on the sure battles
because I want to go out and I want to
fight and I think I will fight with a
full heart and ready to go rip someone's
head off much better than if it's a
right crazy contested thing but I I I
heard uh Robert Whitaker say something
about how he feels that he gets passed
up for opportunities because he doesn't
engage in in all the trash talk and like
all the and and he's just a good guy
that he feels like maybe I'm putting
words in his mouth but it sounded like
he thinks that he gets penalized for
just being a good guy and not
controversial with the trash talk
there's there's part of that that's
that's probably true you know I mean we
we as human beings we like to see a
freaking car wreck we like to see we
like to watch reality TV show not
because it's it's uplifting but because
it's freaking trashy and a lot of people
trying to fight like we like tension we
like you know but that's why we love
mixed martial arts that's why we love
fighting it's ingrained in our DNA as a
as a being um so yeah it's tough being a
guy who doesn't really like to be in
that stuff but but then again like their
fights speak for themselves so like
you're you're Best of Both Worlds you
know you get to be a good guy you get to
be the honorable kind of like you and
poier like I I get poier vibes from you
as far as like being a good guy who
doesn't feel the need to talk bad about
people you know who just goes in the
octagon and their fights are just so
explosive that that you're the
guy yeah so I mean if you if you got
that to fall back on it's like well you
can't call me you definitely can't call
me a pacifist or or shy or or Meek or
any of that kind of stuff just go watch
me fight I mean if you sorry I don't
want to sit here and engage with a a war
of words right now and I want to throw a
you know Monster can at you you know
it's like I am who I am if you don't
like me kick rocks if you like me stay
hang on tight let's go was it after the
Tony
Ferguson uh face kick knockout that you
did four consecutive standing back flip
I think it was four I thought about five
but I didn't want to break my leg I
think it was four four in a row right
there that's just That's Heavy and then
like like what's what what's what makes
the difference if you're going to do do
it off the off the cage are on the flat
what's crazy actually is I have never
once in my entire life jumped off of a
cage and did a backflip except for that
one time wow I finally come to the UFC
get a first round knockout over a top
five opponent become the guy yeah kick
down the door to the party of the UFC
and then decide to climb up for the
first time ever and do a backflip off
the top and semi semi landed it right
and then I promised myself I would never
ever do that again Dan does not love
that no no but you know looking back you
know you're like thank God it all kind
of worked out and you know adrenaline
took over and everything's good and my
legs are are fine but yeah I was way up
there like 15 feet in the air that's
fantastic kage she does it every time
yeah exactly so he uh yeah it it uh
worked out I just I remember well I
don't remember actually anything after
knocking them out but for some reason I
just climbed to that cage was like it
was there so it was kind of like it was
there I had to do it like that idea I I
I've been in situations like that man
yeah where you go look back and like
what was I thinking yeah we're just like
something happened there can I ask you
as like a professional athlete what are
the rules around betting on yourself in
Vegas cannot okay from what degree
though cuz like you should be able to
bet for yourself but you shouldn't be
able to bet against yourself yeah no
that that's there's some some truth to
that because couldn't you be like like
tell your buddy like yo bet 10 million
on me to lose and we'll pay out
yeah and just get knocked out like what
degree like can your wife bet can your
friend bet can your cousin bet I think
that sorry I'm going to take over your
question here what was the controversy
around Krauss I'm not 100% sure the ins
and outs of all that but it definitely
had something to do with some Insider
betting with whether one of his guys had
an had an injury or whether one of his
guys actually threw a fight
or that was like cuz you can't have that
much of a stink if you're betting on
your Fighters yeah
James would worked with offshore sports
book a suspended MMA coach yeah I mean
dude like you know you messed up when
nobody is allowed to fight in the UFC if
they're even remotely affiliated with
you yeah so that well and that was was
interesting too I mean it I guess the
amount of bets and the amount of money
that was going on these guys didn't make
a lot of sense because UFC Main Event
you know this past weekend the Main
Event the co-main event World title
fights you might think there might be
millions and millions of dollars being
put on it but I think the interesting
thing with this was these were guys I I
can't even tell you who the guys were
what the names of the fighters were it's
like it could be an undercard fighter
and all of a sudden tens of millions of
dollars and that's I I don't know what
that number is but let's just say there
was a TENS of millions of dollars put on
this no name sorry not the that's
disrespectful but a a guy who's not in
that huge profile right so like okay
this smells weird but yeah right after
this happened we got numerous emails
from 100 Campbell who is the head of the
legal council for the UFC that says hey
no betting on yourself or against
yourself or anything and no close family
members like if my wife they tell you
well yeah and and it's the same they
also had the the letter no having
anything to do with James Krauss that
too yeah so all those Fighters had to
leave that you know to leave that gym
it' be one thing if like James krauss's
Fighters couldn't have Krauss in their
Corner yeah but they can't even be at
his gym yeah he stays in his state where
is he in Texas oh he's in uh Kansas City
okay so uh yeah you just think like if
you're a fighter on your way out and
like you got like a you run into a boy
from high school like yo yeah you know
what I mean like yeah it's n put 10
million on me dude I got $10 million
under my mattress I'm take it to a
sports book and bet against me second
round knockout pay out 300 to1 odds you
know you're just
like like a weird knock I wonder if
that's happened before I mean it must
because it's like how do you how can you
regulate that yeah well yeah I mean it's
uh like they think T Woodley did that
against his fight with Jake Paul oh yeah
but I don't know don't think so I mean
well you saw the he's like okay when I
drop the elbow you oh I yeah I
saw I saw whatever that was there was
some stipulation that yeah it's uh I'm
not a better like I don't bet on any
sports let alone MMA mainly because I
always say never bet on MMA anyway
because even if you're a thousand one
Underdog or a,1 favorite it's just too
volatile it's there's no locks people
can say it's a lock this is a definitely
a lock it's like no dude this is It's
too crazy I would have been on Izzy all
day over son Strickland yeah much better
fighter on paper right and then all
sudden Strickland goes out there and
freaking dude if you look at
Strickland's fights before I he
like like he lost to caner he got
flatlined by Pereira like I mean
it I don't know dude I really think
whatever the situation was with Izzy and
the dog whatever that story was and I'm
not clear on what it was that was in
Izzy's head and Izzy just did not show
up because he was in the octone thinking
about dogs yeah well and Strickland is
the wrong guy to uh to be have a off
night cuz cuz he's one of those guys
that he makes it a dog well sorry lack
of a better term makes it a dog
fight makes it a dog fight no matter
what like
um but you know what I mean like he just
he makes it he makes it a a nasty
grueling tough fight he's in your face
and he's freaking scary so I me he's
fundamentals yeah he's like a cowboy
Cerrone yeah he very freaking very basic
but brilliant and nasty and brutal with
the basics so so day-to-day life right
now like you're with your family how
many kids you got two boys Happ to be
almost seven Happ to be seven in January
and Ace is 19 months old so seven
year-old's already wrestling not
wrestling no playing basketball baseball
football getting let him enjoy all the
team sports right now where he's
building a foundation of athleticism and
movement and that kind of stuff
wrestling's just
too yeah dude Michael Chandler and
ladies and gentlemen skinny Vinnie In
the Flesh are we allowed to say what's
happening we are Vinnie's getting
married on a
Monday
January 15th we yeah we got Scott
Randolph we got Isaac Patterson we got
an effectively empty ranch house over
here in
[Laughter]
Tennessee Lux says I'm not here it's
cool my
baby and uh man what can I say dude it's
so rad here it's so rad I love
it so much man and I love you for
sticking around to the end of the
podcast let's show Michael Chandler some
street team love grab a screenshot post
it tag him because uh man I really
really like that guy and I would like
for him to feel your love and happy
holidays everybody I'm sorry baby I love
you
okay all
right